we've been touring with comedy central
all over the country
50 states you guys in a tour bus every
city
every state has been amazing everything
was going so smooth
until we passed through phoenix
i got to tell you what happened okay
we're on our way to california and in
between the two you know
there's a checkpoint where they're
looking for illegals narcotics
weapons or all three if you're
convenient
and we're rolling through
it's pretty good huh anyway i know i did
a good bus because when i went
she's like this
he's really good it's really good i saw
the bus i saw it
anyways it's uh it's early in the
morning and we're rolling through we get
pulled over and the
immigration officer walks over the
window and you know
our driver you know he's like what's
going on here and our driver right it's
cool dude named dave
he's been driving tour buses for like 30
years he's old and white
and he doesn't care like his favorite
line is and i'm giving
good old dave ryan so the officer is
like what's going on and dave is like
it's a comedian gabriel iglesias and his
entourage of comedians
it's sponsored by comedy central it's
legit
and as they're talking we hear this
outside
hold on our dog has just informed us
that there is something inside this tour
bus that is not supposed to be
here and our driver looks at the
immigration officer and he says
is that what he said
scooby doo
and we're in the back having a heart
attack dave you're going to get us
arrested
next thing you know they asked the
representative of the tour bus to get
off so my name and my face are on the
side of the bus
door pops open and i'm greeted by an
immigration officer with the last name
sanchez traitor
not only did he recognize me the guy was
starstruck because as soon as he saw me
he was like
and when i saw that i said oh this is
going to be easy right we'll take some
pictures i'll sign some autographs and
we'll go
here comes the other guy with the dog
right hey
what's on the bus and i look at sanchez
and he's still
i didn't think nothing of it you know
he's like what's on the bus i'm just
more mexicans
i didn't know right i knew i messed up
because i look at sanchez and he's like
next thing you hear freaking everybody
off the bus
martin my friend alfred my friend noe
freaking one little two little three
little mexicans four little five little
six
everybody off the bus and then they put
us up against the side of the bus so
they could frisk us
for narcotics and weapons guys in the
back show the picture
now notice notice you don't see a white
bus driver in the picture
it's because he took the picture
apparently even after talking smack to
immigration he was still considered
an innocent bystander you guys can you
show the next one
that's sanchez traitor
show the next one
there's a dog and there's where we threw
it
trust me they did not catch me with
anything because my guys are fast
hey if they would have popped me with
something on that freaking tour bus are
you kidding you guys would have heard
all about it
that sucker would have been on tmz uh oh
fluffy's doing puffy
i'm gonna tell you guys the saddest part
of that whole situation was being on the
side of the road
being harassed by immigration okay
meanwhile there are cars driving past
the same checkpoint
and i'm getting recognized and not only
am i fairly recognizable from almost any
angle
i'm touching a bus that has my name and
my face to confirm
that's who we thought it was so i'm
against the bus
and this guy's got his hand on my butt
and meanwhile from behind i hear this
fluffy
[Applause]
he's american
my girlfriend saw the letter she's like
oh your reunion i go yeah i'm a reunion
when is it when are we going um
actually i was i was gonna take my
friend tony because you know we went to
high school together he's my best friend
since high school so i was going to take
tony
you're going to take tony instead of me
that's what's going to happen huh you're
going to take tony instead of me your
girlfriend you're going to take tony
no it's okay
it's okay you take tony okay and i hope
you have a great time
oh thanks i knew you'd understand baby
[Applause]
don't ask too many questions you know so
my buddy tony now we go to a high school
reunion we get there early too
early there's nobody in the banquet hall
so we go upstairs to the bar area we're
watching a basketball game
everything is cool until some guy
recognized me hey you're the comedian
what's up dude dude funny bro let me buy
you a shot
actually man um i have my reunion right
now and and i don't want to show up
drunk
oh i see how it is bro
you're too good huh that's what that's
what it is huh excuse me
george lopez
let's do the stupid shot all right
bartender's shot so he freaking makes a
double
and we freaking cling cling and slam
that i'm like oh
oh thank you man thank you let's do
another one
hey i'm okay thank you see how it is
paul rodriguez
let's do another shot and he kept this
pattern going he must have had like
seven comedians behind his freaking
wallet you know
one after another i got so drunk i could
i was that level of drunk where you
can't even walk straight you got to look
at the ground to navigate you know you
just kind of
i get to the reunion there's a lady at a
table and she's got stickers on the
table that say
hello my name is and then with a sharpie
you write your name i was so drunk
i couldn't even write gabriel i wrote
flaco
which is spanish for skinny so you know
i freaking write that stick it on and we
walk in
the party's going on you know
i'm trying to find a table my buddy tony
took off i couldn't find him
i'm sitting there i'm like oh my god all
of a sudden
the lights come up and the class
president is holding the microphone
hello everyone welcome to the wilson
high school class reunion
let's just cut to the chase find out
what everyone's been up to
and keep the party rocking so she pulls
out a list
who's done this who's done that who has
the most children
some girl in the back seven everybody's
like
now you remember okay all right
she keeps going down the list who's done
this who's done that who
who's been on television everybody at my
table who wasn't talking to me before
you know they weren't talking to me
before now they're like right here right
here right here
no i'm drunk sure enough here comes the
girl
oh we have a celebrity over here come on
say something get
up here flake oh come on flacco get up
here
okay oh come on get up here are you too
good or what
so i got mad and i jumped up i'm not too
good
um hey everybody my name is gabriel
okay gabriel iglesias
um i don't want to say a whole lot right
now because i've been drinking and i
don't want to say nothing stupid
it's really nice to be here with
everybody
i see two girls here tonight
two who when i was in the 12th grade
i asked out to the prom
[Applause]
and they said no well you know what
it's okay it's up let me go
it's okay you know what it's okay
because like she said i've been on tv
and you two girls who said no you got
fat
one of them yells out you're fat too i
know i'm fat
but i was fat in high school i kept my
figure why couldn't you
[Applause]
you know trevor's a cool dude you guys
but we couldn't wait to have fun with
them so let me tell you a quick story
uh we were doing a show in a city called
eagle pass in the state of texas
now casantejano's in the house what's up
you fall from hong kong
so anyway we're doing a show out in
eagle pass texas now i have a friend of
mine named ricocheris who's also a comic
who was on last season who lives in san
antonio texas which is about an hour or
so away
from eagle pass he bought a new car and
he drove from eagle pass
i'm sorry from san antonio to eagle pass
to meet up with us for a show that night
after the show was over he says hey man
he goes
you want to leave a little bit early and
we'll take my car and you can drive it
and the guys can catch up with us
tomorrow in the tour bus
so i'm like cool let's take off so i
tell martine and trevor and the rest of
the guys
i'll see you guys tomorrow night i'm
leaving with rick so we get in rick's
car and i get to drive
we head to san antonio about 30 minutes
into the drive
we start seeing flashing lights on the
side of the freeway and then a big sign
that comes up and it says
immigration checkpoint ahead
don't worry this story ends differently
so anyways i still get nervous you know
i'm driving and i pull up to the line
i'm sitting and i'm just i'm just
waiting for the officer to say something
that's gonna annoy the hell out of me so
i'm just waiting and here comes the
officer and when he saw me he said
oh fluffy
and when i heard that in my mind i was
like i'm not going to jail
she's like dude what are you doing here
i said well we have a show tomorrow
night in san antonio we're just passing
through
where's your tour bus i said well my
tour bus is back in eagle pass with the
other guys
he goes can we take a picture i go what
about you know cars coming he goes there
hasn't been a car here in hours
so we get out of the car we take some
pictures with the immigration officer
and the dog you know
we get back inside he says thank you so
much for taking the picture with me i
really appreciate it man we're just
bored right now
i go really you guys are bored yeah
we're bored i said well my tour bus is
going to be passing through here in
about two hours
and it says we have a new guy on the bus
who's from south africa and he's uh he's
been bragging about his immigration
status and how
he never has problems with customs or
immigration because all of his paperwork
is always in order i'm just saying you
know
if you're bored
next morning you guys i get a text from
trevor okay
you see how cool and calm he is that
text sounded mad i just looked at it and
said
you're a dick
i couldn't get to trevor fast enough to
hear the story right
so martin and i we pull up to the
theater and uh
trevor and he already told me in the car
they dude trevor's mad i'm like i see
traveling like trevor you okay and he
just went off
gabriel it was insanity i tell you it
was insanity they pulled me off the two
of us like i was a common criminal
i wasn't wearing any pants they took
away my passport my cell phone all of my
money
they stuck me in a jail cell with other
criminals
don't you have anything to say i said
dude you said you wanted to be black
[Music]
bye
[Music]
i took uh i took a road trip about a
year ago after i got rid of the beetle
in the suv took a road trip from la to
phoenix to go perform at this club
let me tell you who's in the car i'm
driving i got my buddy armando riding
shotgun he's another fluffy guy we call
him sexy [ __ ]
well i don't call him that his wife
calls him that he's a sexy [ __ ]
anyway in the backseat i got my friend
martin
next to him is my friend felipe so we
take off
we're on the 10 freeway we're passing
all these indian casinos
sorry we're stupid like that anyway all
of a sudden all these cars
start passing me around
i'm getting annoyed because i'm driving
uh
i said next car that tries to pass me
i'm not gonna let him so i'm looking in
the rearview mirror waiting looking
waiting waiting and i see a silver dot
the silver dot turned out to be a little
car with two
hoochies in it right so some of you guys
are going how do you know they're
hooji's because my friend martin was in
the backseat going i feel a disturbance
in the force
they tried to go around and i cut them
off
i'm having fun they're back there
whatever
my friend felipe is in the back seat
yelling at me
what are you doing i go dude don't worry
i'm having fun gabriel you're gonna get
pulled over
dude i'm okay it's cool we're arguing
going back and forth i'm not paying
attention i don't see
a california highway patrol officer
creeping up on us
all of a sudden i hear i look at the
speedometer
102. oh i freaked out
[Music]
the little car that was behind me with
the two hoochies they got pulled over
because they were going just as fast you
know
i'm in the front seat of my car freaking
out oh my god oh my goodness
i'm on the verge of tears from the back
seat i hear my friend felipe
what are you crying for what are you
crying for fool you're not the one with
weed in his pocket are you
[Applause]
you have drugs in the car
i told you to slow down didn't i
but no pikachu knows everything
shoot everybody roll down your window i
hurt the car bundle fart do something
man
cop walks over the window looks in sees
my face
recognizes me from tv right he's like
hey
i know you you're a comedian
yeah you're that guy from comedy central
you're the guy that does that joke about
his friend at a hotel and you crank call
him and you call him a dirty mexican
and then you go but it was funny huh oh
i love that joke
that one and when you go chocolate cake
oh i love that joke
i hate to do this to you but we got two
cars involved i need your license and
registration
okay here you go here you go so he takes
my info goes back to the car with the
two girls in it ryan the whole time he's
back there i tell everybody in the car
check it out he just recognized me from
tv maybe if we have some fun with him
crack some jokes maybe he won't take the
car
i don't care if i get a ticket but as
long as he doesn't take the car mine
will be silly crack a joke my team be
funny felipe what fool
shut the hell up so the cow comes back
to the car
what the hell were you doing out there
before i could think of something funny
to say
from the back seat i hear oh he was
testing the suspension
oh my god this pothead's gonna get me
arrested
officer i'm sorry that's my friend
felipe that's the guy from the special
that's the guy who says but it was funny
huh he's just trying to get me in
trouble i'm really sorry
whatever so he goes back to a squad car
with my driver's license and he's
swiping it in a computer the whole time
he's doing that
he's being yelled at from the back seat
of my
car hey officer thank god you have a
computer
last week we got stuffed in mexico that
fool had a rolodex
the cop starts dying i go oh we got i'm
going we got i'm going i tell my buddy
mondo give me my cds
i take out my bad boys 2 soundtrack and
i pop it in
track 3 is the theme song to cops i tell
my friend felipe tell me when the cop
starts walking okay well here he comes
i cranked that song as loud as i could
bad boys why aren't you going what you
gone what you gonna do
best part now the cop is walking to the
[Music]
beach
even better than that the two hoochies
in the car can hear the music and
they're freaking out they're like oh my
god we're gonna be on tv
the cop goes to the girls gives them a
ticket lets them go
looks at our car and at this point we're
like halfway through the song right
we're like
police
the cop is in the middle of the freeway
dying
he walks over the window and he's like
shut it off
yes sir hands me my license and the
registration
and he tells me gabriel i want you to do
me a big favor i want you to keep this
tank
under 100. you think you can do that
do that for me keep on doing what you do
and you have yourself a nice day
that's it no ticket
no ticket i don't know what possessed me
to look at this man and go
why
how come the girls got a ticket and he
tells me the coolest thing he says
cause they couldn't make me laugh
you don't understand gabriel i've been
on the force now for 26 years
this is hands down the funniest damn
traffic stop i've ever been a part of
do you have any idea how hard it is to
give two [ __ ] a ticket while listening
to cops
i damn near pissed myself i was laughing
so hard
this is going in the books is one of the
funniest things ever happened to a
police officer i swear to god
the only story better than this one is a
buddy of mine pulled over some fat guy
that gave him donuts
so he starts walking away right and just
as i'm about to start the car
so does that mean i can keep my weed
i turn around and yell at my friend too
late the cop is out the window
you want to run that by me again son you
heard what i said fool
oh you think this is a big joke don't
you you think that just cause i gave
your buddy here a break i know who he is
i like what he does
i don't know you i don't like you step
out of the car
i turn around and my friend philippe is
like oh
i am so scared and the cop pulls out his
gun
i'm freaking out i'm like oh my god back
seat my friend felipe
[Music]
i am so scared fool he's good he is good
then he points it at him the look
on my friend felipe's face oh
priceless
[Applause]
are you serious
but that was funny huh